afternoon ah yes my name is David shmoo
D thanks for joining me after lunch
first talk after lunch hopefully you
enjoyed the meatballs
I hear they were good I did not
participate so today we're going to talk
a lot about actually engineering even
though ostensibly this is about artists
but the two can benefit a lot from one
another and so that's the topic I wanted
to explore with you today I'll try to
leave enough time for the sly do
questions at the end
we'll see we have a lot to cover today
so yeah my name is David Shruti and I
want to talk about pipes well kind of
some of you that are familiar with the
arts or have been around the arts for a
while of course will probably recognize
the image on the left that Rene Magritte
image captioned the painting captioned
this is not a pipe of the image of the
right came from an image search I got
the web last night and it's just a pipe
that you can buy I didn't check how much
it cost but if you're in a room with
both of these things of course you can
imagine looking at both of them the
painting and the pipe and the pipe we
know of course its purpose the pipe is
there as a way for you to take in
tobacco right and in fact that
technology of the pipe has actually
become more and more advanced I've seen
people vape actually even at this
conference right so it's it's it's
something with the purpose that we can
define we can point that and say that's
the purpose of that thing
of course it's kind of decorative it's
kind of beautiful but it has a purpose
and if it fails to meet that purpose we
say it's broken right the purpose on the
thing in the left is a little bit more
unclear it's a painting and again you're
in the room with it and the paintings
don't break anything and
wasn't it what is it therefore is it
there to provoke you is it there for
your amusement okay I mean that's pretty
relative right and of course then
there's this like meta-narrative on that
image which says this is not a pipe
because of course what Magritte was
saying is that this is not a pipe this
is an image of a pipe so it is a
tautology as well so it brings us to
this question that I've worked in art
for a long time in technology as well
but as an artist I get this question on
occasion from non artists of course and
it's actually not a question that I find
particularly interesting because the
question itself is the answer what is
art it is unknowable
it is something once you know it its
purpose is to subvert your knowledge it
will never be known it will never be
held okay so the question itself is the
answer the question itself is the
material of art a more interesting
question and the one that we're gonna be
talking about today more is what is
technology I merely some more
interesting question to me a lot of
people get this wrong and I don't know
if I'll have the answer today but will
actually know what the answer is not so
for example that emoji next to what is
technology that emoji the code for it is
art okay that is a painter's palette
with paint on it a painter's palette
with paints is not art Monalisa is the
art right the palette with the paint's
is the technology the palette with the
paint is to technology and technology
allows artists to do certain things an
artist will use technology to stay ahead
of the curve okay painting for example
Rembrandt's right Rembrandt isn't
Rembrandt without the advance of
painting technology Jackson Pollock
needed advance
advancements in painting technology to
pull off his paintings hip-hop for
example if you're not familiar with the
painters hip-hop right people have been
saying poetry over rhythms since people
have been speaking over rhythms but
hip-hop as we know it hip-hop the thing
that sounds and we identify as hip-hop
doesn't happen without the drum machine
these are people relying on a certain
technology these are artists lying in a
technology to advance their craft and so
art is often the technological endeavor
and artists are pretty good at this
because artists kind of it's in the job
title it's in the description at least
you've got to be creative right a lot of
these creative folks or tend to be early
adopters they tend to be intellectually
curious and oftentimes they're
subversive they're subvert a norms I'm
going to use the word subversive miss
user or sorry misuse and sir versus sort
of interchangeably in this talk right
and what they're subverting maybe
they're submitting something culturally
but oftentimes our server ting a tools
and tension and as engineers we make
tools right we make tools that people
use to online date tools to word process
tools to do all sorts of things with
their lives right and that's we build it
with an intention built in and if you're
a person using that tool with the
designers intention you're merely
fulfilling that intention and you're not
doing anything more which is fine it can
be an act of a creative act with that
sort of approach but a lot of times
artists will take what is a screwdriver
or what is a spreadsheet and they'll do
something more they'll use the tool
beyond what the original person intended
it to be used as and that is a new
manifestation it expands the purpose of
the tool and you as the engineer you see
that it comes back to you and you see it
use the new novel ways it's flattering
sometimes they break it sometimes they
make it worse right sometimes you learn
something from it and that's one of the
things that we're gonna be focused on
today so this idea though that there are
these two cultures is some
that has been sort of in my bipolar sort
of sense of self I guess for some time
where I have an engineer as a father and
a and an artist as a mother but these
two cultures the economy between the two
cultures don't just exist within sort of
my lifetime this is a book or lecture by
CP snow two cultures in the scientific
revolution and what he was pointing out
in the 1950s what he was worried about
at the time when he was giving this
lecture he was worried about this divide
and the fact that as a person that is a
writer and as a person that is a
scientist which he was he was seeing
that his friend groups they don't they
don't interact so the scientists do
their thing and the artists do their
thing and there's a fine line and they
don't have a lot of friendships across
that border and he said this this is
dangerous this is not a good state of
being he was very concerned about that
in this lecture and his example that he
gave is is this fact that or at least in
his experience that is artists friends
or his literature friends didn't know
anything about for example the second
law of thermodynamics and it's not about
like being an expert physicist he's not
asking for that but he's asking for some
awareness of the elegance and the beauty
in the and and what it means
on the opposite side hit a lot of signs
his friends that weren't very well right
of course
and they weren't familiar with a single
work of Shakespeare and he said this
this is a problem these two people have
a lot to exchange these two groups of
people and they're not and he expected
that to have a course dire consequences
as of course science becomes
increasingly weaponized and advances
faster than our capacity to sort of
adjust what's happening
and part of why this happens is the fact
that artists have often struggled for
access to cutting-edge tools so this
right here is a
of the EPSA net this is not part of the
internet this was not part of the
internet when it was built this is a
network of the 70s and 80s it was built
by IP sharp associates and it's kind of
hard to tell what's going on here but
the center here with all the lines
coming out of it that Chicago and then
above it that's Toronto and across the
channel that's connecting to London and
over here this is Australia so it's this
worldwide network and so worldwide
network for business people to travel
and of course exchange information right
and it was built for that purpose
there's this other word I have up here
artex and that stands for the artists
electronic exchange and in fact on Epson
that they set up within the corporate
structure access for artists on this
electronic exchange system which was
pretty unique at the time artists didn't
have access to those tools necessarily
except for maybe at a university and it
was so primitive to get an account you
had to walk into an actual physical
office to actually get an account and
log on and we don't have a lot of
records from that era we do have this
particular piece and be looking at a
number of different pieces today this is
the first one this is Roy Ascott la
policia the text and it was a sort of a
community written story there are 11
artists different time zones all around
the world and they each had a character
assignment and you know they essentially
crossed their cultural sort of
boundaries to continue to add things to
this story at assigned times right and
so it was an exercise in sort of rapid
iteration and whatnot this is uh this is
what it looked like it's naturally not a
particularly good story I've read a
bunch of it but you know there's some
ASCII art in there and and whatnot in
different languages
you know I don't remember what that
means but it's part of the story and so
you know we get back to this idea of
purpose and like what what exactly we're
getting from this or what exactly it's
a-- and that is getting from this like
not great story right
of course like eps annette of course was
built for the purpose of making money we
know why that existed why they they they
created they allowed artists on the
network I mean that's beyond my my sense
of what's happening at the time
what possible sort of things could they
get out of it
well there's like just playing around
misuse so you have a thing you're just
seeing what you can do with it poking at
the edges right as an artist as a
creative experimenter Rd so maybe they
had some sort of like far-flung Rd
thoughts around the fact that the way we
often communicate is through narrative
right and if we have better narrative
tools and then perhaps we can enable
business applications and of course um
maybe having people work at the edges of
a system will reveal things about these
the relief of the system which is an
engineering problem and vulnerabilities
of the systems are problems with the
systems so these edge cases as engineers
we get to these edge cases often we
design for the edge cases we try to
think about them in advance that doesn't
work that well but you know it's worth
the effort for sure we've designed tests
also to catch those edge cases and then
ideal and then at some point someone's
going to hack the system it's some way
you know either for fun or for profit or
whatever or maybe even by accident we're
gonna hope that it's white hat and not
black hat but that's how these systems
kind of deal with misuse in a
conventional sense but artists have been
misusing things at the edges
very visibly for a long time in creating
value that is that is very demonstrable
so in that our text example I really
couldn't tell you what the value is of
having a bad fairytale being written on
their particular network but in this
example I live in New York this is a
very well-known example in New York City
this is any Warhol sitting in his
original Factory Midtown and throughout
the last half the 20th century artists
have been moving further and further out
to the edges of New York because it's
still an expensive right at this point
we're always paying $100 a month for
this space in the space that was so
undesirable there was a hundred dollars
a month ended up becoming a film studio
a print shop a recording studio
counterculture Center I mean he became
the factory it became a hallmark right
and slowly and surely ya know he moved
out of that space Midtown became
unaffordable okay but it's not just Andy
Warhol it's Debbie Harry's Lower East
Side
it's Basquiat East Village its
Williamsburg Brooklyn etc etc and what's
happening there is these artists are
pointing to a thing and suddenly people
are saying oh that thing actually is
valuable and you see reflected in the
city because the rents go up all of a
sudden people are investing into
maintenance and building new
infrastructure in these parts of the
city so the artists were at the edges
first pointing to the value of the edge
that no one else was seen right and now
try to get a place in Midtown so on on
this thought of edge cases in value the
early web there's another Wild West
place like the 1960s edges of Midtown
right
this group Jody it's actually two people
they were they're still doing great work
this is one of my favorite pieces of
theirs at wwwwww
WWJD org when you land on the site this
is what it looks like I love this piece
and when you reveal source this is what
you get the schematics for fat man and
little boy and as accurately as you can
depict in ASCII art nuclear fission
alright and of course there's a
concreteness to this that they're
pointing to you okay the bomb hits right
the bomb hits boom that's the outcome
right all that order becomes chaos what
we see you know what we see is the chaos
after the bomb hits and that's kind of
interesting but to me the thing that
really makes this piece kind of great is
the fact that it was built at a time the
web value proposition was unknown and
artists were working at the edges once
again and figuring out what the value is
here in this case they were enabled by
the fact that no one else knew what the
value was of the web at the time some
day were gonna shop for clothing on the
web I'll believe it when I see it right
someday we're gonna put our credit card
numbers in all this other stuff we had a
sense I mean the web was being
commercialized by this point by 1995 we
had a sense where it was going but we
didn't know exactly what was going right
and so when they were building these web
sites of course they made it it made the
decision of course to allow the source
to be revealed and that's because how
valuable could the source actually be
now later on when Apple gets involved
and they make an app store right what do
they decide they decide of course as
part of that app store do they put in a
reveal source I mean these are just web
widgets
okay Internet widgets that are pulling
information right no of course they
don't because we knew what the value
proposition was of that app store and
they took this different model of the
model of box software for coming off the
shelf at at computer stores right so
it's just a different business model
it's a model where they knew the value
in advance though right so okay looking
at another piece from 95 the Jodi and I
have a little trouble getting this one
to work all the time but I were lucky we
got it going here
it's called automatic rain this one had
to be emulated in an old netscape
navigator web browser because it doesn't
actually work anymore and contemporary
browsers and it actually doesn't
actually work in this browser very well
either again from 1995 you click on it
and it's hard to see here it's a little
washed out but it's the blink tag okay
and there's these blue numbers kind of
raining down it's going too fast though
in the olden days this would take a
little while to render all the text
right and so it would be raining down
rain they're all actually links you
click through and this image of rain
loads and you saw how it went down well
imagine this is a dial-up speeds the
rain would just be slowly cascading down
your screen right again Jody's doing
this sort of concrete manifestation of a
piece the thing they're misusing here is
speed speed was for the engineer as an
impediment but for the artist the speed
was the feature and the reason the
artist could see the speed was the
features because of they're just
misusing something that was there that
had no value to anybody else but
slowness can be a feature engineers have
engineered slowness into computers you
guys remember these turbo buttons on
these machines does anybody here
remember that anybody old enough to
remember yeah turbo buttons engineering
slowness keeping your machines slow
enough to run at four point seven seven
megahertz to run old software so there's
value in slowness right and engineers
will make things slow when the value
proposition is clear the artists will
make things slow they'll miss use things
when the value of proposition it's not
the last jody piece i want to look at
we're not gonna look at because this has
not
in I've not been able to find this
anymore
but again creative misuse Netscape won
one had a bug in it and the bug created
a situation where you could have one
head and multiple bodies and the way
that Netscape won one would render that
is it would render it one body at a time
and so the people at Jody decided hey we
could animate with that and this was
before flash it was before JavaScript
this was the original web animation was
before animated gifs and so for about
eleven months there was a whole thing of
there's a few artists working in the web
that were misusing this bug leveraging
it to create these animations of course
they were obsolete within 11 months of
course and so we see is a situation
where this misuse can on one hand
perhaps hasten your obsolescence the
work that you're making artist can
actually hasten things hasten the
momentum of or the value of an object or
implementation but they can also when
they're kind of working at the edge
influence the system itself which is the
next thing I wanna look at so this is an
early animation in 1963 it's one of the
first known computer animations and this
is what it looks like as it goes around
and of course what the engineers at Bell
Labs we're doing in the 60s to say
thought well this is going to be great
because we have all these models of
various things in time and we can
finally see what they look like we can I
finally see what an orbiting body looks
like around a satellite there and so
they saw of course immediately the value
proposition in this but then they did
something kind of weird at Bell Labs
they brought in the artists and the
artist said oh that's interesting let's
do some weird stuff with it
and
when Lillian shorts came in she had some
pretty interesting ideas about how
animation should work with computers and
so around the time that that first image
that first animation that I showed came
about ken Knowlton who also worked at at
Bell Labs started on his DSL the main
specific language for animation called B
flicks and they actually did a number of
art pieces together with Stan Van Der
Beek before Lillian Schwartz came in but
she looked at it and she's like there's
there's one really big problem with this
she identified the problem to language
right away and the fact that like any of
the generative work that you could like
create within be flicked it didn't it
didn't hold from frame to frame
okay so animation is all about one frame
at a time right
and you could do that in B flicks but if
you want to generate something that
information didn't actually move between
the frames and so she saw that as a
problem and she designed and helped
instrument and implement this Explorer
language let's see if this is loaded
unfortunately I can't grab her stuff off
the web so this is her website it's an
awesome website I think she got Lillian
calm which is amazing but yeah so let's
watch a second of this there's a little
sound see that comes through the sound
was also done about labs this is what it
looked like
pardon the compression
yeah I should come with a seizure
warning - sorry about that but this is
odd I mean I kind of love this piece as
well
and all of these shapes are generated
and so if you ran the film multiple
times it would come back with multiple
different iterations here but of course
it was only meant to be run once because
it was actually meant to be print to
film right and so what came out of that
creative misuse for features so you
created an animation DSL you create the
most complete and thorough and brilliant
animation DSL known to humankind which
is really what can no did because he
created the first one so there was no
other one to compete with and of course
some artist is going to come in and ruin
that that's their job right their job is
to subvert and she says well this could
be better because of this so no matter
what you do with your DSL and I'm sure
anybody who has made a DSL for any
purpose someone's gonna come in and mess
it all up be like I want to expand it
this way and you're like that's not the
intention and then then they they fork
it and they create their own DSL and all
of a sudden we have 10,000 node packages
but misuse can also be beneficial and
get long-term features in fact these
features were used at Bell Labs for
tests and vision or experiments with
vision experiments with animation and
sofa and so on that were educational so
yeah it actually had also practical
engineering purposes and scientific
purposes as well this is a piece by
David M that he did at the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory which is a NASA
run space in California in the 1970s and
this particular piece he did a number of
interesting stills this particular piece
is notable because of how these um how
these grids kind of curved and undulate
and the reality is is of course that was
a bug I was not forced to come out that
way
but he's like hey this is pretty
freaking great and then these engineers
do what they do and they fixed it they
fixed the bug and so what did he do he
added in a randomized routine right and
what he's pointing out is that misuse of
course is this very human thing this
random thing the messiness see
engineering the goal is certainty the
goal I mean we never get there but we
want to know how long this bridge is
going to stay end up right we want to
know that this formula is going to give
us the correct name this algorithm is
going to give us a correct answer every
time it executes okay we want to have
that certainty but then you live real
life and you don't get that okay you get
all this great stuff called serendipity
and you get all those other horrible
stuff called accidents and that's it
that's what you have you don't get the
engineering part and that's why people
respond to this stuff that's why the
artists will come back in and add this
uncertainty because because they can see
ways to make the product to make the
experience more human because art is
really reflecting the human experience
and engineering is reflecting some
idealized experienced it's a piece by
Dianna Smith called Francine done this
year that is done in CSS by hand so she
paints not with a some sort of you know
pin or something like that this is done
this is mostly hand coded here's her git
repository for the Francine that's what
it looks like it's quite remarkable
anyway yeah you can see just how crazy
all of this is if you load yeah it's all
one line of course one line of code
it's brilliant there it is
right if I'd run one recommendation is
be like comment your code I can't read
this no obviously not okay so yeah quite
quite remarkable and the thing about
this piece in 2018 I've been looking at
all this stuff from the 70s and 80s with
you guys with y'all and here we see like
in 2018 it's the same stuff just decades
later because people are just gonna do
this it is just the reality of software
it is just the reality of engineering
people are going to misuse it because
they like to write or because they don't
know any better and they make an
accident right so ones are ones an
accident in life right but this is
reality and it's and it's up to accept
the up to engineers to accept the
reality and see how we can leverage this
reality some of my favorite things that
she showed when I saw her talk recently
she ran this through older CSS engines
and it's and I was I was really very
impressed with this the fact that the
system still kind of holds up right the
the form is still there the the
intention is still there even as we go
all the way back and her face kind of
slides off into our body it's it's still
there
and miscues misuse coloring working at
the edges and eating at the edges it can
give us really actually sound and
practical reflections about the system
itself it can tell us if the system is
robust that's the thing that was so
impressive to me about the CSS example
was wow it's that consistent that we can
still get that kind of form as we go
back through the previous engines I mean
people complain about CSS all the time
but that's quite remarkable we can also
see how expressive it is obviously CSS
is so much more expressive than it used
to be
the last piece I want to look at today
is this piece pot at order cuts he is a
Brazilian and he was working in he was
working in video text which is
implemented on the Minitel network in
Brazil
so the minitel network was another non
internet network bringing it up here was
a non was another non internet network
this one it was very common in France
various places in Europe it was also in
Brazil this is what it looked like this
is actually a Minitel terminal so we're
getting the experience of what it would
have been like in 1985 and what we have
is sort of like this a that kind of
comes out of the background and then
these little stars around it and if you
look closely of course that fills out
the rest of the word of abracadabra and
it's an interactive piece in the sense
that you you you have to go out
presumably you're in your home or you're
at a public place with these network
terminals and you have to go out and
grab the piece download it run the piece
and then it will keep looping it's
called Rio briquette opera not just one
half of Cadabra
so yeah so he he made this kind of
clever piece of neo concrete poetry so
concrete poetry is poetry that is that
is reflective of the material that it is
pointing at poetry describes something
concrete poetry also looks like the
thing that it is describing so that's
that's what that's why it's situated
this way and the thing is this
particular piece and actually all of
these pieces that are that are older
they bring up a really interesting
question around digital preservation
these systems of course are very hard to
maintain
unlike unlike the Mona Lisa which was
referred to earlier and it just keeps
coming down from century to century to
century I mean we can't even get stuff
working from 40 years ago because
engineers didn't design it to be
long-lasting they designed it to get it
done you know ship it remember okay so
what we actually have is a piece where
it's its essence has changed from an art
perspective it was something that was a
piece of what it's called telematic art
tel Ematic art has a long history from
male art to fax machines to email where
artists would send things over the wire
and that was part of the piece in Rio
Bert Cadabra the mini tool network is
gone and that port terminal is
connecting to a thing a reality that
thinks that it thinks is the mini till
Network but it's just a simulation okay
and it's really of course removed from
its original intent it's a pastiche
because it does not have the network
aspect involved it's actually now
technically it's just computer animation
it's not telematic at all and the thing
about having a piece like that where its
essence still seems the same but
something material has changed about it
it's its purpose becomes well as unclear
as it ever was I mean what was why did
Edward Katz Eduardo Katz make that I
mean what was the purpose of that art
piece right it has no clear application
it has no purpose it's in fact its
essence has changed right and what's
happening here is of course this is not
the thing this is not the pipe this is a
simulation of something that someone
experienced in the 80s that points to
the actual art piece of music of neo
concrete poetry so this is not the pipe
it points to the pipe this is not the
experience we had in 1985 in Brazil when
we got the thing when we got rehab
cadabra it is
pewter animation that points to the
original experience so it's essence has
changed its purpose is obfuscated the
fact is it's not actually it's a
pastiche of what it was it's still
valuable and it's still art we can still
see that as art we can still point to
that and say I get all that it's not
really what it was but it's still art
right and the expression has changed
only because the technology changed
around it so coming back around then
we've circled around this whole question
about what is technology and we get
caught up on that screen that terminal
the network is that the technology okay
is that technology the problem that we
have as engineers too often is we get
blinded by the screen the terminal the
purpose all this other stuff because
that's what we think the technology is
it's it's that but that minis whole
screen is still able to communicate and
to show this place in time that is still
meaningful and it's still art so it
can't be just the screen it can't be
just the network it can't be just just
the terminal itself and the keyboard I'd
argue that technology is is the entire
system of engineering and so that
includes all the things that you touch
every day the code all the things you
think about all the time the design all
the things that underlie it the physics
to make it possible but it also includes
the social relationships because that
also makes this possible it also
includes the education the background of
the people that you work with it also
includes the culture that's all built
into the technology technology cannot be
removed from culture and the thing that
artists are good at the one thing
they're good at besides not making money
is is culture its culture so
I guess the only thing is bringing
artists in early talking to artists
making art a part of your life that's
the ask that is will make you a better
engineer because culture is part of
everything that you make whether you
like it or not thank you
[Applause]